wissenschaftler finden wir dass kein
kater verursacht der größte
teilchenbeschleuniger der welt bekommt
doppelt so viel power und wir schicken
2018 den ersten organismus auf den
master sind drei der fünf themen jetzt
bei den blick zum 250
alkohol ohne kater ich hoffe ihr hattet
alle ein schönes silvester und saatgutes
neue jahr gekommen doch es kann gut sein
dass einige von euch am neujahrstag mit
einem kater aufgewacht sind und dass er
am ersten tag des neuen jahres alles
andere als bach und frisch war das
könnte bald der vergangenheit angehören
denn australische wissenschaftler haben
einen gefunden
das laut eigenen angaben keinen kater am
nächsten morgen verursacht alkohol
verstärkt nämlich die produktion von
urin was wiederum bei übermäßigen konsum
dazu führt dass euer körper dehydriert
also entwässert wird der mangel an
wasser ist es also der euch am nächsten
tag kopfschmerzen und übelkeit bereitet
die wissenschaftler haben sich das
zunutze gemacht und dem bier elektrolyte
hinzugefügt diese haben einfluss auf die
wasser produktion im körper bis jetzt
funktioniert das bier ohne karte nur bei
leichten bieren also denen die sowieso
schon wenig alkohol besitzen
die forscher möchten weiter an ihrem
produkt arbeiten sie sind zuversichtlich
dass ihre lösung in zukunft auch auf
andere biersorten anwendbar ist die
beste nachricht daran tester konnten das
elektrolyt wir nicht vom normalen bier
unterscheiden
der zusatz ist geschmacksneutral für
alle die trotzdem nicht warten können
nach der silvesterparty wieder wie ein
kleiner tipp trinkt im laufe des abends
immer mal wieder ein glas wasser um
euren körper nicht dehydrieren zu lassen
das ist gesünder für euren körper und
erspart euch den kater am nächsten tag
der erste organismus auf dem mars wird
ein salat ein studentenprojekt aus
england wurde nun als eins von zehn
universitäts projekten ausgewählt die
2018 auf den mars fliegen
der flug von maßnahmen der dazu gedacht
ist nutzlast auf dem mars zu bringen
bevor die ersten menschen dort ankommen
wird unter anderem ein kleines space
gewächshaus mitbringen in dem salat
wachsen kann
damit wird das gemüse der erste
organismus auf dem mars der von menschen
dorthin gebracht wurde
die gefrorenen salat haben werden
zusammen mit wasser nährstoffen und
einem ausgeklügelten überwachungs system
zum mars geflogen
sobald der salat anfängt zu wachsen wird
ein heizungssystem die temperatur
zwischen 21 und 24 grad celsius halten
also
die auf der erde eine kamera wird
regelmäßig dokumentieren wie gut der
salat wächst am ende des projekts sorgen
die heizstrahler dafür dass der salat
vollständig zerstört wird damit auf dem
mars keine organismen zurückbleiben die
der umwelt dort womöglich schaden
könnten die studenten das projekt und
die wissenschaftler von mars one
erhoffen sich durch das projekt weitere
erkenntnisse über den anbau von pflanzen
im weltall und auf anderen planeten zu
erhalten
bis jetzt deuten die ergebnisse darauf
hin dass pflanzen unter geringer
schwerkraft zwar überleben können
allerdings keine gesunde
nahrungsgrundlage für menschen
darstellen krebs ist oft keine frage des
lebensstils der lebensstil oder die gene
einen menschen sollen in zwei dritteln
aller krebsfälle nichts mit dem
auftreten der krankheit zu tun haben
eine studie der john hopkins university
hat die ursache für krebs in über 30
verschiedene gewebetypen untersucht und
kamen zu einem beunruhigenden schluss
egal wie gesund man sich ernährt wie
viel man sich bewegt oder wir ein die
luft ist die man atmet jeder mensch hat
ein risiko an krebs zu erkranken und
dieses risiko steigt beständig den krebs
kann immer dann entstehen wenn sich zwei
zellen teilen und die dns reproduziert
wird wenn dabei ein fehler auftritt
entsteht eine mutation sie sich dann
weiter teilt bis irgendwann krebs
entstehen kann
die forscher fanden nun heraus dass mehr
zellteilung in einem gewebe mit einem
erhöhten krebsrisiko in zusammenhang
gebracht werden können die entstehung
dieser mutationen lässt sich leider noch
nicht kontrollieren die zellen in
unserem körper müssen sich reproduzieren
damit wir gesund bleiben
diese neuigkeit ist allerdings kein
grund um jetzt völlig sorglos und
ungesund zu leben rauchen erhöht das
krebsrisiko zusätzlich enorm und zu
langes sonnenbaden ohne schutz er wird
auch weiterhin das risiko an hautkrebs
zu erkranken
nur kann man leider trotz aller
vorsichtsmaßnahmen nichts gegen das
krebsrisiko generell tun aus diesem
grund wird vermutlich in zukunft die
krebsprävention auch verstärkt im
jüngeren alter gefördert denn das
erkennen von krebs in einem frühen
stadium bietet immer noch mit abstand
die besten aussichten auf eine heilung
smartphones verändern unser gehirn die
verbreitung von smartphones schreitet
unglaublich schnell voran viele von uns
benutzen ihr handy mehrere stunden
täglich und jeder zweite von euch guckt
dieses video gerade auf seinem
smartphone und obwohl smartphones
inzwischen zu unserem alltag gehören gab
es bis jetzt noch keine studie dazu wie
sich touchscreens im alltag auf unser
gehirn auswirken bis jetzt
wissenschaftler der universität zürich
haben nun studienteilnehmer mit hilfe
von eeg es beim benutzen von smartphones
beobachtet es wurde getestet wie stark
bestimmte bereiche des gehirns aktiv
sind wenn probanden zum beispiel eine
nachricht schreiben
das ergebnis die studienteilnehmer die
regelmäßig smartphones benutzen hatten
wesentlich höhere aktivitäten in den
bereichen des gehirns die für die finger
verantwortlich sind
je häufiger ein teilnehmer in alltag zum
handy greift desto stärker sind die
ausschläge des eeg es die autoren der
studie kommen deshalb zu dem schluss
dass unser gehirn sich an den täglichen
gebrauch von smartphones anpasst unsere
daumen
die früher nur gebraucht wurden um eine
schwer zu halten müssen heutzutage
wesentlich präzisere aufgaben übernehmen
und fordern deshalb mehr aufmerksamkeit
vom gehören die studie beweist wie
unglaublich anpassbar unser gehirn sein
kann
nach einer gewissen zeit der umstellung
können wir probleme lösen die uns früher
unmöglich erschien
sie geht mit doppelter bauer wieder an
den start
der leistungsstärkste
teilchenbeschleuniger der welt der large
hadron collider wird 2015 wieder in
betrieb genommen der beschleunigungs
ring mit 27 kilometern durchmesser hat
im jahr 2012 das higgs boson das
sogenannte gottesteilchen gefunden nun
nachdem der lg zwei jahre planmäßig lang
repariert und verbessert wurde können
die forscher teilchen mit bis zu 14 tera
elektronenvolt schwerpunkt energie
aufeinander prallen lassen das ist
doppelt so viel wie bisher und die
teilchen erreichen dabei bis zu 99,999
99 9% lichtgeschwindigkeit
experten erwarten nun da
der enormen zusätzlichen power weitere
portale entdeckung so zum beispiel die
von teilchen aus der die sogenannte
dunkle materie besteht
es wird vermutet dass dunkle materie
einen großteil unseres universums
ausmacht und das aus ihr die kraft für
das sich immer schneller aus denen der
universum kommen dunkle materie ist
eines der größten rätsel der
wissenschaft unserer zeit mehr darüber
gibt es in diesem video dunkle materie
gefunden
und hier unten geht es wie immer zum web
und dort allerdings noch deutlich auch
in der video beschreibung jetzt bin ich
wie immer auf eure meinung gespannt
würdet ihr bier mit elektrolyten trinken
damit am nächsten tag keinen kater
bekommt diskutiert ist wie immer mit mir
in den kommentaren und ansonsten sage
ich bis dann bleibt dran